tricks with us in Miami hi Patrick
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey
thanks taking my call sure what's up so
I just graduated about a year ago got a
job making 40k and I'm trying to decide
between paying down my loans which is
thirty thousand at four percent or
investing in retirement and you know
maxing out a Roth IRA because I've been
reading about you know the power of
compounding and I'm not sure if it's
worth it to pay down my my debt as soon
as possible when when it could be more
worth it to you know just max out those
desire raises yeah well what you're
dealing with here is a theory that
doesn't work in real life
okay and here's what I mean the theory
is is that you're making money on this
spread by not paying off a 4% loan and
putting it in mutual funds that make
more you're making money the actual
facts are that when we did the largest
study on millionaires we found zero
millionaires out of ten thousand 167 of
them that we surveyed 0 of them that
kept debt around because they made money
on debt right and so millionaires just
don't do what you're talking about so if
you want to be a millionaire you don't
do what you're talking about you pay off
the student loan as fast as you possibly
can and so that you can take advantage
of the power of compound interest so
your y24 yep cool what's your degree in
finance actually good good which is
making you use your you know your math
skills to look at this equation and
that's smart to do the thing you're
leaving off is risk and debt and that
inherent in it is risk and this feeling
this malaise that the student loan is
hanging around your neck you know
there's a monster in the closet and
there's just a thing that affects the
math but it's hard to put math to it
that when you're free of Sallie Mae you
have a higher tendency to prosper that's
what all the data points tell us from
studies and so yeah you definitely want
to clear that student loan as fast as
you possibly can and then avoid debt
completely and that is your shortest
route to debt or so shortest route to
wealth hey thanks for calling in